there probably is no more graphic an
illustration of just how bad the
coronavirus crisis is hitting india than
this
this is a makeshift crematorium it's
actually
not meant to exist this has been set up
by the residents around here
who cannot cope with the number of dead
behind me are all the funeral players
that
represent a mother a father a daughter
a a son an uncle a loved one to someone
a friend
to someone each one of those fires is a
coronavirus death
and we have been watching in the just
the last few minutes alone they've been
coming in
virtually every second they simply can't
cope
and this is not one of the official
funeral sites
this is a an ad hoc one one
they're bringing in the wood as we wait
to to prepare from yet more casualties
coming in and this is on top of the
official sites remember
many of these people don't feel that
they're represented in the country's
statistics
they feel even though india is facing
not just a grim spike it's almost like a
consistent
wall of coronavirus cases and deaths
they reckon this is just what one
economist called the tip of an
iceberg but underneath that terrible
grim
statistic showing the huge number of
cases and
possibly the deaths that that will
follow there's
a much much bigger worse case scenario
of numbers who knows how many who are
unaccounted for who are unlogged as
coronavirus
casualties coronavirus cases coronavirus
deaths we heard in just today i think
it's been
very much compounded by the government
the local governments the local
authorities very much
being unprepared to cope with this
second surge
of which they had plenty of warning
following as they were
a cycle behind many other countries who
were suffering
their second surge not least britain
they instead were embarked on a number
of political rallies
all of them attracting hundreds
thousands of people
their vaccine has rollout has been
a little bit well
difficult to describe it as anything
other than slightly chaotic although
they are vaccinating
an awful lot of people because this
country
is so populous it's actually less
only a few percent of people who are
actually vaccinated
and while they're still determinedly
trying to roll out their vaccination
they haven't prepared for this huge
spike and this huge
sudden spike which means that many of
the hospitals particularly in the north
of the country in where i am in new
delhi the capital and
other areas in the north they have been
left
wanting for oxygen they have been left
seeing that there is not enough oxygen
supply which we
know is so critical
for coronavirus patients
there is as you can imagine an awful lot
of
um grief an awful lot of anger
and shock that they've been left in this
position they held a
a a religious festival which attracted
something like
10 million devotees
and all those people may well have been
super spreaders
or could be infected or certainly a
large number may well have been in fact
and they have been asked to go
into isolation and this is
going on 24 7 right now they are the
fires that
simply do not stop burning they're also
predicting
that the peak has yet to come it may not
come until the middle of may
so these terribly terribly bad
statistics of the number of
cases followed by an increasing slow
increase in the number of deaths could
well become
an awful lot worse and alex
um tell us about the reaction from
people in india
to how slow the government's been in
trying to
put up an uh extra infrastructure i know
prime minister modi held a meeting just
two days ago about
the shortage of oxygen in hospitals too
little too late perhaps for the people
there
prime minister modi himself has been the
object of much criticism
because he has been at an attendant and
a
leader of many of these political
rallies there are
a number of elections going on across
india
and as one delhi resident told me
it if you've got an election going on in
your area
you pretty much and you're a politician
you seem to be telling everyone there's
no corona virus
in delhi there is no election and that
is why there seems
it seems to uh the politicians and
perhaps the residents are much more open
in showing
that there is a terrible spread of
coronavirus they simply
can't seem to be able to cope with it
right now and they're also coping with a
number of different
variants they they they are blaming in
many
cases the national disease of
central control in india seems to be
blaming
the british variant for having come and
mutated here and they're very much
putting the blame on the british variant
for causing this
dramatic surge in india so there is an
awful lot of criticism and awful towards
the government authorities and certain
political parties
there's a lot of squabbling belief
between the political parties
who are in charge of different states
some of whom are
blaming rival political parties for
hindering the
spread of oxygen supplies to fellow
rivals and the high court met today
to impose very strict ruling that if
anyone is found to be
restricting oxygen supplies they could
face
a death sentence to try and stop this
happening we were outside
a queue a very long queue in the center
of the capital of private citizens who
are lining up
having bought their own oxygen cylinders
to fill them up
to treat um their relatives at home
because a lot of the people that we were
speaking to today are very fearful about
trying to take any sick relative
into a hospital which many of whom are
saying they cannot cope and they haven't
got the oxygen supplies
to keep their relatives alive in one
hospital alone today
in delhi 25 covered patients died
for lack of oxygen according to the
hospital administrators
these are all terribly frightening
statistics for the residents in this
area
and throughout the country and as i say
there's a very
deep worry that this could be far far
worse
if it's happening in the capital it
could be far far worse out in
the rural areas